This gives a visualization of
what is happening in learning
by recording cases.
There's a new problem a shown by the
color here, and memory contains a large
number of cases, again represented
by the different colors here.
So we retrieve the case b that is
most similar to the new problem a.
In this particular case,
we're deciding by color.
And whatever was the solution to b,
we apply to the situation a.
While this visualization is useful,
it's still very abstract.
Let's think in terms of some practical,
everyday examples.
So you get up in the morning and
you want to go for a run.
You put on your sneakers,
you have to tie your shoelaces.
Well, how do you tie your shoelaces?
That's a new problem.
But of course, you have tied
shoelaces many, many times earlier.
So you have a memory of tying
shoelaces to different kind of shoes.
That's all's to it is
cases in your memory.
So as you start tying the shoelaces for
the shoe today,
you simply retrieve the closest
matching case and apply it.
None of us really thinks very hard
in the morning about how exactly to
tie shoelaces.
If you were to do it,
it would take us a very long time.
So in learning by recording cases,
memory guardedly supplies
us with the answer.
We don't have to think about it.
>> So another example of this that
comes to mind is in programming.
Oftentimes in programming, we deal
with the same type of problem over and
over again.
So I might imagine I'm
starting out a new program and
I'm writing a program in Java.
So I'm given a new problem of
creating a new program in Java.
All I'm going to do is look
back in my memory of cases and
retrieve another case of
starting a new program in Java.
And I'm going to apply the solution
to that program directly to this one.
In this case, it's going to be something
like, when I'm starting a new program
in Java, last time,
I started with public static void main.
I'm going to apply that solution
directly to my new problem,
and it works.
The solution can just be transferred
directly to the new problem without any
kind of modification.
Then later in developing that same
program, I might hit, for example,
a null pointer error.
I'm going to use that null pointer
error as a new problem and
use it as a probe into my memory.
I'm then going to retrieve a case of
when I encountered a null pointer error
in the most similar program I've worked
on, and then that's going to give me
a solution that I potentially can
apply directly to my current problem.
So for example, the solution to the last
time I encountered that same error
might be to run the program in debug
mode and allow it to tell me exactly
what variable is null at
the time of execution.
>> That's a good example, David.
And we could even try to generalize
it to medical diagnosis.
Imagine that you went to a medical
doctor with a set of signs and symptoms.
So the doctor is faced
with a new problem.
What is a diagnosis for
your signs and symptoms?
The doctor may even have a number
of cases recorded in her memory.
These are the cases she has
encountered during her experience.
So the doctor must select
the most similar case,
the most closely resembling case,
which in this case might be b, and
say that I will apply to a exactly
the same diagnosis that I applied to b.
So a case then is an encapsulation
of a past experience.
And learning by recording cases
is a very powerful method
that works in a very large number
of situations ranging from
tying your shoelaces
to medical diagnosis.